love is not blind
does anyone actually believe that it is
genuinely curious
because I genuinely believe love is not blind
and that TV show Love Is Blind only proves my point
it's just not okay
men are initially driven by looks visually
and they stay for personality or intelligence
typically it's about looks for men okay
they don't know you
they don't know your personality or if you're funny
all they care about is if you look good
like understanding personality and character to them
it's beyond them initially okay
they don't care about that
they care about looks
that's why this show is
love is blind is so hilarious to me
and they're all like oh
I'm looking for love
I don't care about looks
and then they see their partner or who they fell in love with
and they're all shocked
no brainer there
love is not blind okay
you fall for someone or you're interested in them for their looks at first,
and then you fall in love with their personality and character
y'all have second thoughts after
and okay some do end up working
but I'm just saying for majority
love is not blind
mmm mmm but come on
you can't tell me love is blind no